rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée la découverte de la forêt
des hauts de montvert rendez vous sur la
planète du tampon côté plaine des cafres
la forêt des hauts de montvert est situé
à côté de celle de notre dame de la paix
au départ de la piste nous retrouvons
s'il ducret du parc national
avant l'installation de cette nouvelle
barrière le départ de la randonnée
pouvait s'effectuer un peu plus loin
désormais les premiers passeront donc
sur la piste carrossée jusqu'à cette
seconde barrière où commence la piste en
terre
belle forêt de bois de couleur des eaux
située sur une enclave de la commune de
saint pierre est bien entretenue par le
g7
la forêt des oignons verts se découvre
tipa tipa grâce à la piste large et peu
accidenté les espèces pays sont à portée
de main le laurent martin l'eps yade ya
des fleurs jaunes les mao
quant aux espèces exotiques elles sont
peu présentes et quand la piste est
large i de trot déchanter de
replantation d'espèces endémiques ont
été conduits avant il ya quelques années
vraiment très récemment il y avait une
grosse grosse poche de raisin marron
c'est en fait la mouche bleue et le
travail de l'homme qui ont permis de
d'éradiquer on va dire le raisin marron
ou du moins de 2 de réduire le raisin
marron
soit on retrouve encore quelques tâches
à proximité et suite à ça il ya eu des
espèces indigènes de plantes et donc
qu'ils vont reprendre petit à petit le
dessus et normalement ça devrait plus
avoir des postes raisin marron a
repoussé à cet endroit là
la piste n'étant pas très loin du bord
de remparts on pourra parfois il jeter
un oeil par quelques trouées
mais attention il n'y a pas de point de
vue aménagé seulement ça et là quelques
traces de moins en moins visibles soyez
prudents la vue donne alors sur la
rivière des remparts et sur grand coude
mais mais
dugarry tard mon devoir
où
hachey
quand la piste commence à descendre la
traversée d'un champ élargi l'horizon
c'est ici que l'on retrouve des agents
du gsm en plein travail
leur mission du jour et fastidieuse
l'arrachage de l'ajonc une entre espèces
exotiques envahissantes
mais attend comme ça il ya trois jours à
l'écouté enrichi 3 joie donc là il ya
une campagne au moins pour trois mois
bon alors on avait fait ça depuis van
2012 soit 12,6 revenir malgré
l'entretien l'âge on est effectivement
encore très présents sur la zone
grâce à son énorme capacité de
renouvellement plus bas la vue dégagée
vers le nord-ouest permet d'apprécier
toute la planète du tampon et le massif
du dimitile c'est aussi l'occasion de
voir du dessus cette belle forêt au
premier plan derrière nous tu peux voir
la forêt encore de bois de couleur des
eaux et une de ses caractéristiques
c'est que tu as l'éléphant gens qui
dépassent de la forêt la forêt de bois
typique de bois de couleur des eaux une
canopée dans les dix mètres de hauteur
que contrairement à la forêt
le bois de couleurs débat qu'on peut
trouver sur marc long qui elle une
canopée beaucoup plus haute est donc
plus on va monter en altitude plus la
strate arboré elle va baisser
donc on aura une canopée au fur et à
mesure mais plus petite à cette
intersection un petit crochet permet
d'atteindre ce magnifique point de vue
d'ici il est possible de rejoindre le
domaine vie dot
sinon de l'autre côté le sentier peut
continuer jusqu'au domaine du relais de
petite-île
mais pour nous la randonnée se termine à
la barrière
moi ce que j'aime sur cette randonnée
c'est l'accessibilité en fait par
rapport à la piste et on peut découvrir
donc de façon assez facile une forêt de
bois de couleur des eaux et ensuite les
paysages qui vont du piton des neiges
jusqu'à la mer c'est un chantier qui est
pas difficile donc c'est assez large
ou pis donc on peut amener aussi bien
les marmailles que les personnes qui ont
des difficultés pour se déplacer
l'autre intérêt du site c'est que en
fait il va y avoir des indigènes qui
vont être plantés et du coup le on
n'aura plus que cette petite portion
piste où on passera qui laissera une
trace dans le paysage mais tout autour
on aura une forêt encore bien préservé
ce que j'aime moins ce sentier en fait
c'est que quand tu arrives là comme ici
à la fin de la randonnée
donc effectivement tu peux prendre le
sentier le soin de faire petite île où
vers saint pierre mais tu as pas de
réelle book qui permet de rejoindre le
début du sentier